al franken once wrote a book titled lies
and the lying liars who tell them and
that reminds me
of or that came to mind as i think of
the next two topics we're going to cover
here's brad holmes
the lions general manager when asked
today
if he would definitely not draft a
quarterback with the seventh overall
selection here he is
oh no i would no absolutely not um
you know uh i don't think i don't think
when you're picking
this high uh that you can be out on
any position uh but obviously
quarterback
is such an important position and you
know i just think it's good
it's good drafting business always to be
to be very very thorough on that
quarterback class regardless of what
your situation
is that's from the huddle and flow
podcast with steve weiss and jim trotter
and look
i made this point yesterday as it
relates to the eagles i wrote about it
today
the last thing you want to tell is the
truth when you got one of these top 10
picks and there's going to be
quarterbacks trickling down through the
top 10
and you either want one if you want one
you don't want anyone to know you want
one because then you may as well plant a
flag that says
quarterback is being taken here so
anybody below you
that wants a quarterback what do they
got to do they got to get up above you
i think that's why the eagles have
leaked the idea that jalen hurts is the
guy without competition you never should
leak the truth
or what you actually think you should
leak the opposite of it
so that you know when you see the
bengals at five and there's a
quarterback on the board mac jones
potentially still there
i had no need to trade up he's gonna
fall past past the eagles at six well
maybe he won't because maybe they're
lying about what they really think and
for the lions
the flip side's true you want if you're
not in the market for a quarterback
shireen
you want to act like you are so teams
will jump ahead of you
take a quarterback because you're not
going to anyway and what does that do
it pushes down the board a guy that
you're more likely to want it's that
simple
so we go through this every year take
with a grain of salt anything that
anyone says
or anything that a team leaks because
they should never let us know what
they're really thinking
yeah no question mike and you know i
think brad holmes thinks a lot of jared
goff
and i don't think they'll take a
quarterback i think they
should take a quarterback if they're
sold on one of these guys i think they
should have drafted justin herbert with
the third overall pick last year
they didn't they passed on them and we
see where they are now they had to trade
matthew stafford and they're starting
over with jared goff
and who knows how long he'll last there
is their quarterback mike
another example of it we're not going to
play the sound but dave gettleman the
giants gm
said today that they're not in the
market for a quarterback that's how
you that's that's how you protect your
spot
and not worry about someone jumping one
spot in front of you
to get a quarter pack you have to
conceal
what you're truly thinking unless these
folks are operating at the jedi mind
trick levels
and these aren't the droids you're
looking for and and and
so we really want a quarterback so we're
going to act like we want a quarterback
so they think it's the opposite
i'm giving myself a migraine but yeah
it's it's all
bs they should not be telling anything
close to the truth
unless they are trying reverse
psychology in the reverse of that and i
i need
i need a nap after talking through all
of this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports